I'm Jamie and I'm addicted to water
slides
I've always felt at home in the water
and like a fish the log has dropped 2011
completed it in Aisle eight er 1998
survivor so in pot noodle challenged me
to spend less time cooking you're more
time chasing my dreams I knew what I had
to do become a professional waterslide
testimony
[Music]
hello I'm Jamie must be here so what's
in store for me this week well you're
gonna be learning how to become a
waterslide tester and at the end you're
gonna be sliding down the scariest slide
on the park with people
[Music]
so you have to get chains into trucks
all right this way that way so what do I
need to know when grading the slides
well there are three things have to have
in mind while sliding down the
adrenaline if it's stress relieving or
stressful
the biggest surprise when you hit the
water and the coolest feature so what
makes the the slide unique and then a
total score that's it yeah that's it
[Music]
oh just got back first day done it's so
much fun
Oh Becky ring as well bring on day two
[Music]
and all the riots are tested him apart
from one
it holds me in my dreams 114
[Music]
one sec one sec one sec one sec are you
right now Jamie anyway ready to go yeah
I'm good and three two
[Music]
so how did I do
I think you did great you nailed it and
you've got what it takes to be a pro
waterslide system ah thanks thank you
very much thanks this has been
absolutely amazing an incredible week
it's been so enjoyable I put on every
single slide now conquered my fears
I've really enjoyed myself it's been an
absolute blast it was really tricky I
thought it'd be easy but it wasn't but
I'm playing for your world I'm coming
for you I'm going to every single water
park and let it every single slide
[Music]